NCIS Los Angeles has dropped a bombshell
Rene Felice Smith's Nell Jones is
planning to leave potentially for good
at the end of the show's 11th season but
what's the real reason Nell will no
longer be part of the show on the
episode entitled fortune favors the
brave
Nell's reason for wanting to leave is
revealed the job has changed her so much
that she even struggles to get out of
bed in the mornings to come to work she
confessed as much to Kensi blye early on
in the episode I don't think I want to
be an agent anymore okay
Kensi tried to suggest that Nell rather
stick to her old base of ops rather than
going out into the field as an agent but
that wasn't the solution Nell was
looking for either counts I'm gonna
resign from NCIS though Kensi suggested
a holiday and was supportive at Nell's
confliction and struggles she was
somewhat less supportive of her desire
to resign from the team to be fair the
job Nell wants to leave behind is a
tough one with plenty of grief and
stress involved
[Music]
between that and the personal troubles
Nell has endured with her mother's
illness it's completely understandable
that she's having serious doubts about
her job right now Nell was previously
touted to be taking over from operations
manager Hetty Lange who has also been
fairly absent on NCIS Los Angeles
recently she seemed like she'd be the
perfect fit for the job but just a few
episodes ago
Nell's future on the series suddenly
became unclear instead of pushing to
keep Nell in the fold
Hetty indicated that she was instead now
looking at Callen to take over for her
when the time comes
Hetty being Hetty it seems she was well
aware that Nels inner turmoil would
probably lead her to walk away from the
job opportunity now be gone the episode
closed with Nell finally telling Hetty
that she was resigning but the ever
stoic operations manager gives her
another option before she makes her
final decision in headies view Nell is
free to leave if she wants but first
she's going to have to burn through a
few weeks worth of unused vacation days
if I don't hear from you once they've
elapsed you can consider yourself
rezoning that unused vacation time
indicates that Nell may well be
suffering from a serious case of burnout
between working as hard as she does and
spending time at her sick mother's
bedside Nels head is likely spinning too
fast in every possible direction which
could easily be the cause of her high
stress levels and lack of desire to go
to work when Nell walked away to tell
Eric about her decision she stopped for
a moment to look around the office
seemingly saying goodbye to the place
that had been a second home for her for
almost a decade her relationship with
Eric also seems to have suffered lately
with the pair appearing to have
communication issues a relationship
between Eric and Nell was long hoped for
by NCIS LA fans who noticed their
flirtations early on and hope to see
them seal the deal it looked like their
relationship was finally confirmed but
Season eleven has brought them some
unexpected troubles episode 19 son Nell
desperately trying to avoid talking to
Eric at every turn something that's not
usually a good sign in a relationship
when major decisions are
made are you avoiding me what and even
though there have been hints of Eric
also waving goodbye to NCIS the turmoil
between him and Nell might instead see
the couple split actor Barret foa's time
away from the show during the early
episodes of season 11 were to allow the
actor time to appear in a play his
return to the small screen in the ops
center has seemed to be fairly permanent
despite him previously looking for jobs
in San Francisco where Nels mother is
being treated Nell isn't in the preview
for season 11th 20th episode if she has
decided to leave will fans get a chance
to see her again or has she already
disappeared for good like many other TV
shows have had to do recently NCIS LA
has had to cut production on the current
season short instead of the usual 24
episodes of season 11 fans will only get
21 this could mean that the uncertainty
around Nels decision may be dragged out
even longer than originally planned if
her vacation days haven't elapsed by the
time the truncated season reaches its
end so far
Rene Felice Smith hasn't yet made an
official announcement about leaving the
show but a recent Instagram post of hers
directed fans to tune in to see a
wistful Mel on Sunday night the studio
hasn't confirmed that she's definitely
departing the team leaving fans no
option but to keep on watching to see
where Nell ends up check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]